to think that now that behavior is going
to change is not realistic
States incoming Secretary of State
Democrat Cisco Aguilar sounding off
about his beaten rival Republican
election denier Jim Marchant Aguilar is
set to take on the mantle in January but
the question is but what can we expect
under Aguilar's leadership eight news
now investigator Vanessa Murphy talking
one-on-one with him to find out
one is making sure that nevadans
understand that elections are fair
Democrat
State News Now for a live interview
during his race for Secretary of State
his opponent Republican Jim Marchant
also agreed to an interview but was a
no-show Aguilar won did you receive a
call from him and what do you want to
say about him you know unfortunately I
don't expect to receive a call from my
opponent given his behavior and his
actions throughout the campaign one he
never presented himself to the Nevada
voters he hit Aguilar's Victory now in
the National Spotlight for an office
which until false claims a voter fraud
were made in the 2020 general election
didn't get much attention the Secretary
of State's office handles business
matters like licensing and overseas
elections all eyes were on Clark County
with the getting the ballots processed
should the system change you know mail
ballots are new we're still learning so
what specifically would you fix so we're
not sort of waiting a long time again
for the general election I think one of
recognizing the fact that Nevada is such
a deep purple State you're going to see
these issues you still have elections
that are occurring in some of the house
seats across this country and I think
the fact that Nevada is a deep purple
State we have to ensure that we get the
accuracy and we get the legitimacy in
our elections to show make sure the
results that voters accept while Clark
County received criticism for its Pace
in processing ballots Registrar of
Voters Joe Gloria insisted he was
following the law and using all
resources he had should any dates change
as far as the mail ballots or should for
example Joe Gloria have more bodies and
more machines I think it's my
responsibility as the future Secretary
of State to say hey
Joe let's come together let's have a
conversation where can we be better what
can we do to help make this process
stronger for everybody for me to make a
statement flat out right now without
talking to Joe and getting his
perspective on the way things went how
soon after you're sworn in will you
start those conversations
um I'm starting them now with learning
the Secretary of State's office meeting
with the current Secretary should every
absolutely every voter every eligible
voter right legal voter should get a
mail ballot the reason why is if you
look at who Nevada is we're a very large
state from a geographic perspective but
we're also 24 7 economy we have
individuals who are working 12-hour
shifts and to go back to a single day of
voting on Tuesday just isn't logical for
our community in our state